Would you all meet
George Carlin.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
-Hey, baby! What's happening?
(MAKING FUNNY SOUNDS)
We got assholes, scumbags,
jerkoffs, and dipshits...
-and they all vote.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
He was funny, he was smart,
he was opinionated.
I wanted to be just like him.
He was just so cool.
Here's a list of words
you can't say all the time:
Shit, piss, fuck, cunt,
cocksucker, motherfucker,
and tits.
-And the crowd goes crazy!
-(AUDIENCE UPROAR)
-Shit, piss, fuck, cunt...
-Cocksucker, motherfucker...
-And tits.
They arrested me for profanity.
SPEAKER (OVER RADIO):
The Supreme Court restricts
the broadcast of dirty words.
STEPHEN COLBERT:
He's on the juncture right now.
He's the Beatles of comedy.
GEORGE CARLIN:
I began this dream
of standing in front of people
and having their attention.
KELLY CARLIN: My mother
was his biggest champion.
She just had a way
of lifting people up
and believing in them.
They were comrades in arms.
But then, what happened
was superstardom.
My mom was alone all the time.
She's feeling left behind.
And now the drugs are there.
And it really did undermine
everything in our family.
I did as much cocaine
as there was
in the immediate
three-county area at that time.
He had collapsed in on himself.
GEORGE: My career began to wane.
I had to find my voice.
(AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
In 1988, we were gonna go
to the show to laugh at him
'cause he was this older comic.
And Carlin came out with,
like, a howitzer.
Now, they're thinking about
banning toy guns,
and they're gonna keep
the fuckin' real ones!
He didn't want to be
that George Carlin anymore.
He wanted to be
a different George Carlin.
GEORGE: What I really was,
was a rebel.
Can't educate our young people,
can't get healthcare
to our old people,
but we can bomb the shit
out of your country all right.
(APPLAUSE)
♪ ("UP AROUND THE BEND"
BY CREEDENCE CLEARWATER REVIVAL
PLAYING) ♪
Stand up's the hardest thing.
He did the hardest thing
for the longest time.
He was challenging society
to be better.
Life is sacred?
Who said so? God?
Hey, if you read history,
you realize that God is one of
the leading causes of death.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
George is still relevant.
He changed comedy
three or four times,
and he's still talking to us.
Things that he was getting at
were so profound to the culture.
What would you do
if you were the planet
trying to defend against
this pesky species?
Hmm, viruses.
They try to divide people
so that they can run off
with all the fucking money.
Bullshit is the glue
that binds us as a nation.
It's the American Dream
'cause you have to be asleep
to believe it.
♪ Come on the risin' wind
Yeah! ♪